well the one thing I have looked at and  it's not my internal polling is polling  that I've seen out there the more that  the Democrats lay out the case this the  weaker their case becomes independence  seemed to be parting him the president's  numbers in the battleground states have  gotten stronger the president's case  against those who are running against  them have fallen we're I saying  internally you have 31 Democrats who sit  in seats the president Trump carried  their numbers have continued to drop  having spoken to Democrats I see the  nervousness of what they have their own  internals I've watched that they've been  reported that they've had had inside  their own conferences arguments with  their leadership that they're not  defending them  you